[Music]
a texas courthouse employee
pleads guilty to spiking her co-workers
energy drinks with colon cleanser what
accident no that's like an old joke
right no the actual
like liquid that you cleanse your colon
with oh what's that like
juice yeah i didn't know there was enoma
juices hey you guys live in la i feel
like this is very topical yeah a lot of
la people like doing coffee enemas yeah
i heard that i heard a coffee
i want to try it and suntan in your
balls that's very l.a i don't think
there is an actual benefit yeah what is
the point of an animal it's supposed to
flush out your in intestines before you
get a colonoscopy yeah for a real one i
have the coffee one i think i've heard
that
are kind of akin to like douche where
like it doesn't actually like your body
can kind of take care of it on its own
that's what it's supposed to do you
might need an enema if something
specifically happens in there some extra
it's not something you do just to
maintain just wait back on suntanning
your balls yeah you never heard of that
hella do that
honestly out of all the things not dark
enough no it's supposed to be for like
testosterone and nature oh
you never heard that you know what's
funny it's like all these things that
are very la are never
created by la people it's created by
some [ __ ] crazy person that wanted to
be an actor and they come to l.a and
then all of a sudden like they go crazy
because they did too much drugs and then
now yeah the l.a was a joke like a lot
of you guys are from l.a which isn't who
i'm making fun of i think that's what's
funny yeah yeah it's the imports yeah
the imports are for sure the crazy ones
people definitely come up with these
ideas on like markets they can create in
la that are completely
like someone's going to buy them and i
don't really think they believe them at
all i was going to do that [ __ ] i was
going to scan the [ __ ] out of la with
this one idea i had
was it i was going to start a [ __ ]
musical therapy
where like that's got to be real
at the time i didn't know anything about
it but because you're just making it up
you're just doing the tambourine
feel bad i'm just playing a [ __ ]
rubber band
and i was gonna do this shooting anxiety
i was really just gonna be a [ __ ]
hack and be like oh yeah you know people
come to me they tell me the problems
i'll play what they're saying to me out
in music back release the energy and but
you're actually good on the keys yeah
but honestly and i think what could do
it is yeah i think it would actually
work because i'll feel good i'll tell
you this over here though this this is a
poster boy
look at this
bye-bye depression yeah yeah
i think l.a is full of people like that
that figure out these things that people
are gonna buy and they don't [ __ ]
believe in that [ __ ] themselves at all i
think it's great
but yeah i think the crystal craze came
from the l.a crystals man those are very
powerful the crystal craze and the birth
charts and the [ __ ] you know last
time i was at melrose flea market there
was like a whole table of crystals i was
with this girl and she goes i was like
don't she's in a crystal so i was like
how come you don't want to buy these
ones and she goes are you kidding all
these people walking by them those are
totally like they have no more power
zapped
yeah they suck the energy she's not
wrong you can't sell crystals that way
where everyone can just walk by and suck
all the energy out of it yeah because
all the electrons and i went what about
the [ __ ] miners that took them out of
the ground
that's not just they don't count
shouldn't they have amazing lives all
the murders along the yeah along the way
they're just like surrounded by
himalayan salt they should be [ __ ]
so like prosperous so prosperous i love
the stories that they've going to work
the next day mining true that's like
what's the two riki reiki yeah frankie i
know i'm not in the crowd to make fun of
that
anyway
some of y'all like what you mean
religion like my mother
i don't think you mean you mean western
medicines i don't break is not my thing
this is a this is a lady that did the
little prank to her co-workers and the
reason it doesn't look like a prankster
i think this is really funny because
listen to this her name's uh
her she's her name's hernandez and this
is her thing she told her employees the
liquid was spark energy drink and after
her employees consumed it she started
singing you just drank colon cleanser
wow it's just the worst prank ever
or is it no so she started making fun of
the employees and i gave you cyanide i
gave you signs because like it said
oh gee like prank to pour in some uh
x-lax yeah
you've got [ __ ] all day
this is like these are courthouse
employees right it's not like [ __ ] we
work so it's a little bit like that's
true we work this is okay
just [ __ ] colon cleanse the dh
no i think the company is too yeah yeah
but they're sold yeah
but yeah that's um reworked yeah we
crashed no really that movie just came
out it's called wheat crash like a real
one a real movie that just came out um
no way and anne hathaway and uh somebody
else jared leto love it
it's about wework yeah yeah yeah it's
called we crashed it's like it's like a
dramatization
the documentary is pretty good though
yeah we covered it in the podcast you
know one of the biggest reasons though
why they pumped up so [ __ ] hard is
this like one japanese billionaire dude
like um
he uh they convinced him to give him a
hell of money he's like the jeff bezos
of japan yeah like and then he [ __ ]
pumped so much money and then like yeah
they they probably wouldn't had it
without that backing total side note i
hate it but the guy who the wework guy
if you watch the documentary and i've
never met him but in the documentary
everyone's interviews like oh he's
always so charismatic you would have
bought into in every clip i see i'm like
this guy's a [ __ ] idiot like i would
never buy this guy's [ __ ] like he he
comes across as some [ __ ] uh do an
impression of him guys i can't can't but
like like russell like russell brand
acts in movies oh like he is in uh
forgetting sarah marshall yeah he acts
like that so he's like supposed to be
obnoxious like a guru kind of [ __ ]
whatever yeah i guess that's charismatic
no
russell brand in general is very
charismatic but not like his character
i'm just like no way am i giving this
guy my money nah but that's you have a
lens to be able to spot that maybe i got
a [ __ ] radar yeah hey buddy he
fooled a lot of billionaires billions
no he's way more charismatic than me i
haven't full [ __ ]
i can't even get a date
yeah so the um
basically the employees started
they were in in huge like tremendous
pain in their stomach
do you think she's still laughing at
this point that's the main thing is like
anybody who's like a city worker if
they're caught [ __ ] around in any
capacity i think that just gets more
attention than somebody at [ __ ] but
anima juice especially on the [ __ ]
core enema juice though yeah a bad idea
where do you even buy that i mean okay
even if it was a laxative right let's
say if it was a laxative the judge is
going to be [ __ ] [ __ ] his
attitude that's funny during the harvest
like that is hilarious during a homicide
case you're like
[Laughter]
or just like slap the thing every time
you do the fart to hide your fart
i guess she was kind of like her
reputation around there was that she was
sort of a bully so they were kind of
happy she's sacked like she's gone yeah
because she resigned after that is there
a lawsuit that's about to happen
no there's not they're not which is kind
of ironic that the courthouse employees
are not doing a lawsuit how many people
did she spike because they're like we
don't believe that justice here yeah
this thing works it's like four of them
four
pick one when you think like courtroom
at least me i always think like old
people too i think the judge is like 75.
yeah you know what i mean i'm like who's
pranking people at 75 what the [ __ ] are
you doing yeah do older people get
inside the workplace like that
i feel like like the senior centers they
probably do especially because they're
just chilling all day that's more like a
frat house
women i feel like are not known
pranksters either especially of that
delivery that's pretty good what would
you have done i mean i've done similar
things to that like x-lex well because i
i think i told you guys like my roommate
um a long time ago when i first moved to
hollywood was like they would do this
prank to me where they would [ __ ] um
sign you up for free samples of [ __ ]
like a ton of [ __ ] so anytime i got the
mail which would be a ton of free
samples of of uh what's it called like
diuretic cookies
like cookies that make you [ __ ]
just tons of them i was like where the
[ __ ] are these cookies so when my friend
was like who did it to me was like
groggy and asleep i just kept trying to
make him i just could put him in his
mouth
and i was just like he should [ __ ]
eat it he just [ __ ] was like oh i
don't know and then eventually he just
said [ __ ] fine they just started eating
them
so yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
so yeah it worked and i you know i'm i'm
a big prankster i like doing [ __ ] like
that we had like we had like a two-story
ceiling and i i put all these mops
together to make a gigantic stick and
right before he had to go to the club i
took his uh id and credit card and i
taped it to the end of the stick and i
put it on the ceiling
so right when he had to leave he was
like how the [ __ ] did that get up there
that's so funny how did he get it down
yeah those are funny
well because i took the stick apart he
had no he was just figuring it out but
how did he have to get it down i had to
get it down i told him i was like i made
this stick
out of like
four
like a broom i just spent three hours
yeah making all these sticks together
and now you're late
but then i can't imagine like see like
if i had a grown-up job like like her
and i had this adult thing i would have
that bone i need to like i have that
itch
i think bodily harm to a person is uh is
kind of a lie yeah i think i think you
work up to that that's the thing like
you you go back and forth and it leads
to that but apparently she's the only
one doing it to people and then that's
[ __ ] up i also think the more serious
the job the more you have to [ __ ] around
you know what i mean i feel like you
just have to especially like something
like surgery for sure
like a doctor doing brain surgery like
you know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you